so just kind of making sure you don't
you don't miss anything it's a very
solid reaction and the among those Blitz
is outward takes a fake it will be a
Perpetual let me just briefly consult
uh consult the Oracle yeah he wasn't
really much worse it wasn't anything so
rookie seven was playable rookie seven
was playable but the the end result is
still a draw another very difficult draw
either you know so this will end in the
draw
with madnesses uh sequence of two wins
in a row stopped by by kukashu until
round eight had a horrendous tournament
and the tournament could have actually
gotten even worse because he was at one
point close to losing uh against uh
Parham as well but that game ended up
going his way
and now he holds a very solid game
against Magnus where he had to solve
some tactical issues and then had to
kind of be unafraid to go for the same
game you never really like allowing